bonsoir nous sommes le 20 novembre il
est 18h si vous nous rejoignez en direct
et voici les principaux titres que nous
allons développer ce soir journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant
alors que la France vient tout juste de
ratifier le protocole de 2011 qui permet
au mineur de saisir le comité des droits
de l'ONU nous revenons ce soir sur les
événements organisés dans le département
en plateau notamment une élue du conseil
municipal des jeunes de la verrière et
la responsable du Conseil Municipal des
Enfants de Guyancourt dans le cadre de
l'opération Père Noël vers Dieu Secours
populaire des Yvelines la direction de
La Poste des Yvelines s'est associé
aujourd'hui au collectes de jouets pour
les plus démunis hommes politiques de
centre droit mère sénateur des
Pyrénées-Orientales Jean-Paul alduit a
aussi été en région parisienne directeur
général de l'établissement public
d'aménagement de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'ancêtre de
la communauté d'agglomération rencontre
à suivre tout à l'heure à l'occasion de
son passage à Saint-Quentin donc
peu après 9 heures ce matin Nabilla
Benattia très tirée et visiblement
éprouvé est arrivé devant la chambre
d'instruction de la cour d'appel de
Versailles la vedette de téléréalité
soupçonnée d'avoir poignardé son
compagnon demande de sa remise en
liberté selon ses avocats sa détention
provisoire n'est plus nécessaire nous
nous sommes venus dire à la cour que
cette détention provisoire doit être
exceptionnelle c'est la loi qui dit et a
fortiori lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'incarcération d'une jeune femme de 22
ans l'enquête a déjà évolué que
notamment la partie civile a été très
longuement entendu et que par conséquent
il n'y a plus lieu de craindre des
concertations qui auraient pu peut-être
altérer la sérénité de l'instruction
incarcéré depuis une dizaine de jours à
la maison d'arrêt de Versailles Nabilla
traverse sa détention avec une grande
force et ne se plaint jamais c'est en
tout cas les mots de ses avocats mais la
réalité de ce dossier c'est une jeune
femme de 22 ans qui est incarcérée c'est
ça la réalité de ce dossier et elle je
trouve qu'elle oppose à ces regards
extrêmement
ants de l'extérieur une force et une
dignité tout à fait stupéfiante donc
elle se bat mais elle comprend très bien
le mécanisme judiciaire d'après une
source judiciaire la cour d'appel de
Versailles a finalement rejeté la
demande de remise en liberté Nabilla
reste donc toujours en détention pour le
moment
20 novembre 1989 était adopté la
Convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant 191 pays l'ont ratifié santé
liberté d'expression éducation
protection contre la discrimination elle
permet de réaffirmer que l'enfant doit
être respecté au même titre que l'adulte
plusieurs actions sont organisées dans
le monde en France dans les Yvelines on
notera le vendredi 29 novembre que les
élus du conseil municipal des enfants de
Guyancourt organisent leur dixième
édition des droits de l'enfant tout au
long de la journée des élèves de CM1 de
CM2 de 6e vont participer à divers
ateliers bonsoir Jessica Moreno vous
êtes la responsable du conseil municipal
de ces enfants de la ville donc à
Guyancourt on notera aussi que le
mercredi 26 novembre ce sera au tour de
la verrière de ce mobiliser avec le
conseil des jeunes et l'association
Enfants du petit pays bonsoir Amel Taj
tu es membre du conseil des jeunes de la
verrière et bonsoir donc à Romulus à
kinocho bonsoir donc et Valérie Centaure
vous êtes respectivement vice-président
et responsable marketing de cette
association des enfants du petit pays on
va commencer forcément forcément
aujourd'hui comme c'est à la journée des
droits de l'enfant avec avec Amel 14 ans
journée des droits de l'enfant ça
représente quoi pour toi bah alors c'est
un jour on va rendre hommage aux enfants
et alors à trouver leurs droits qu'il
mérite un moment important c'est
important de rappeler que les enfants
ont des droits je vais donner quand même
quelques chiffres pour pour resituer la
situation 76 millions d'enfants en
situation de pauvreté dans les 41 pays
les plus riches de la planète chaque
heure ce sont 300 enfants qui meurent de
malnutrition dans le monde pendant ce
temps en France 300 000 enfants en
danger de maltraitance 600 000 qui
souffrent de mal logement lorsque vous
échangez au sein du conseil municipal
des jeunes vous parlez de tels
problématique vous on parle forcément de
des droits des enfants lorsque ça va
plutôt bien dans le pays on se rend pas
forcément compte que dans certains pays
c'est encore plus compliqué oui vous
échangez autour de tout ça alors il y a
plusieurs commissions et du coup ben on
sur ces différents commissions on aborde
les thèmes
qu'on considère important et bien
effectivement on va revenir sur les
conditions de vie des enfants etc
importantes c'est pas uniquement
l'aménagement des arts de jeu ou autre
qui sont débattus au sein de ces
conseils ces conseils des jeunes
justement à Guyancourt comment ça se
déjà ça s'est mis en place conseil
municipal des enfants
le conseil municipale des enfants existe
depuis 1990 donc ça fait déjà 24 ans
qu'on donne la parole aux enfants et ce
qui leur permet d'exprimer leurs idées
et de mettre en place des projets pour
l'ensemble des enfants de la ville et
c'est vrai qu'ils sont souvent attachés
à des projets solidaires envers les
autres enfants pour améliorer le
bien-être aussi des autres sur la
dixième opération 10e fois qu'il y aura
cette journée des droits de l'enfant
organisé en tout cas sa forme actuelle à
aiguillancourt comment ça se déroule et
qui le met en place ce sont les enfants
eux-mêmes qui alors le service plutôt
directement qu'il met en place mais les
enfants du conseil municipal nous
accompagnent la thématique cette année
est en rapport aussi avec le centenaire
de la guerre puisqu'on va travailler sur
les droits de l'enfant en période de
conflit haut de guerre montrer aussi
l'importance de l'éducation et la chance
qu'ils ont notamment en France d'avoir
accès à l'éducation pour aller à l'école
d'avoir accès à l'eau potable chose qui
n'est pas toujours facile dans d'autres
pays comment ça va se dérouler pour
cette journée concrètement donc on
travaille avec des partenaires de la vie
voilà tout à fait et des travers celle
que l'UNICEF Amnesty ou la Croix-Rouge
et ils vont mettre en place des ateliers
de 40 minutes pour sensibiliser les
enfants de la ville donc ça touche les
enfants de CM2 et de 6e donc on a à peu
près 500 enfants sur la journée et ils
viennent participer à des ateliers et
échanger débattre de leurs droits qui
est aussi également le penchant qui sont
leurs devoirs les devoirs également même
si on parle beaucoup des droits les
devoirs aussi vous les plus jeunes en
sont conscients il y a des devoirs aussi
quand on est jeune
c'est difficile un peu d'apprendre ça
aux enfants mais je pense qu'il y a pas
que il y a des droits il y a des devoirs
et donc
doivent respecter les autres obéir et
mais aussi savoir défendre leurs idées
les enfants sont des adultes comme les
autres ce qu'on disait un petit peu en
introduction tout à l'heure on en vient
donc à La Verrière à cet événement
organisé ce sera le 26 novembre
oscarabée travail mené notamment avec
votre association on va présenter
l'association dans un instant mais
comment concrètement vous allez vous
impliquer sur cette journée alors donc
le 26 il y aura pardon le 26 il y aura
donc
un atelier au scarabée avec des comptes
de 9h à 11h30 on va recevoir les enfants
de maternelle avec différentes activités
comme chant danse
saine ouverte aux enfants et puis il y
aura un concours de dessin et des
enfants seront remerciés par EPP enfant
du petit pays avec des cadeaux et
l'après-midi à partir de 14h donc il y
aura on recevra des enfants des écoles
primaires donc pareil là il y aura chant
danse compte et puis ce qui est
important il y aura aussi un débat sur
les droits des enfants et des enfants
seront remerciés par oui il y aura aussi
la présentation de amnistie
internationale donc ils vont expliquer
ce qui fait des actions qui mènent qui
sont et puis ensuite il y aura ils
seront il y aura un concours de dessin
des libération on va vous donner des
cadeaux et puis au PP leur montrera que
le geste qu'ils ont fait est super
important ce jour-là et on leur donnera
aussi un cadeau vous avez travaillé avec
le conseil municipal des jeunes de la
commune mettre en place tout ça oui en
échange oui tout a été fait avec en
partenariat avec Amnesty International
avec aussi la mairie de la verrière et
puis toutes les écoles la plupart des
écoles de la verrière également comment
vous les trouvez ces jeunes très
réceptifs à toutes ces problématiques
très impliquées en général oui parce que
il faut dire que EPP a l'habitude de
donner des actions avec des enfants et
ça j'ai pu assister et franchement il
est en général il répond toujours
présent l'objectif de l'association
aider à l'intégration des immigrés
soutenir les familles défavorisées vous
pouvez nous représenter un petit peu
cette association enfants du petit pays
il y a une adresse Internet notamment
qui s'affiche pendant qu'on parle
d'une association
socio-humanitaire donc dans le premier
objectif c'est l'intégration donc à
travers les intérêts associations c'est
à dire effectivement on dit petit pays
on vient on vient tous d'un petit pays
et pour faciliter l'intégration passer
par différentes associations ça peut ça
ça aide beaucoup donc c'est la première
des choses ensuite c'est vrai que nous
on a un développement vise aussi un
développement à l'international à
travers les enfants c'est à dire l'aide
scolaire donc c'est très important
puisque les les enfants d'aujourd'hui
sont les adultes de demain donc ça
commence dès le début donc voilà c'est
principalement les points sur laquelle
travaille en fond du petit pays et donc
le travail qui sera mené le 26 à
l'occasion de cette journée des droits
de l'enfant le 26 pour la verrière le 22
pour Guyancourt et tout cela et piloté
bien souvent par les conseils municipaux
des plus jeunes des jeunes ou des
enfants ça dépend des communes comment
tu t'es impliqué toi dans le conseil
municipal des jeunes de la verrière
alors
dès le début en fait dans toute la ville
il y avait des affiches etc et donc je
me suis dit que ça serait bien de
m'impliquer un peu dans la ville de voir
son fonctionnement etc et donc j'ai
décidé de me proposer après on a été élu
et lorsque j'ai été élue on a choisi nos
commissions et c'est là en fait qu'on a
commencé à nous impliquer vraiment on va
choisir les faire des propositions pour
des projets etc du siège dans quelle
commission action de solidarité alors
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de mener comme
projet qu'est-ce que tu m'aimes comme
projet alors il y a des actions que j'ai
déjà réalisées comme un resto du coeur
en fait avec les restos du cœur j'ai
décidé enfin on a décidé de faire un
luxe au resto on appelait ça comme ça
c'est un repas solidaire et tous les
bénéficiaires des Restos du cœur étaient
invités dans une salle de scarabée et
manger du nez gratuitement donc le repas
il a été assuré par des jeunes de la
ville qui s'étaient proposé et ça avait
plutôt bien marché
ça ça enrichit aussi toi tu te dis que
c'est bien de s'impliquer pourquoi pas
s'impliquer aussi plus tard une fois
adulte au sein des conseils municipaux
ça m'a apporté beaucoup de choses parce
que grâce à ça j'ai pu ben ça fait comme
de l'humanitaire puisque c'est solidaire
etc donc bah ça m'a apporté l'expérience
ça fait que j'ai découvert ma ville même
si je la connaissais déjà avant
et ben j'ai côtoyé des personnes que je
connaissais pas et j'ai diagogué avec
eux et ça m'a beaucoup apporté sur la
maturité qui est affiché là et qui est
commune à tous les jeunes qui
participent à ces conseils municipaux ça
vous surprend ou qui est en contact
régulier avec les jeunes quand on dit
les jeunes s'implique pas les jeunes
s'en moquent
c'est ce qu'on recherche c'est à dire
que c'est des jeunes c'est des enfants
mais comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est des futurs adultes et c'est dès le
jeune âge qu'il faut commencer à
s'affirmer avoir une personnalité voilà
c'est c'est tout à fait bien commencer
en tout cas avec le recul puisque le
conseil municipal des enfants est plus
ancien sur la ville de Guyancourt que
deviennent ces enfants qui s'impliquent
ensuite ils continuent politique ou à
s'impliquer dans des associations c'est
vrai que nous ils sont élus entre le CE2
et la 6e donc ils ont la possibilité de
faire un deuxième mandat quand ils sont
encore en CM2 on a bien souvent
déconseillé qui se représentent pour une
un deuxième mandat et qui souhaitent
être mère enfant puisque c'est un petit
peu plus de responsabilité et c'est vrai
quand on regarde après le parcours des
anciens conseillers bien souvent ils ont
un changement au moins associatif après
sur le plan politique je ne sais pas
mais associatif et notamment dans
l'humanitaire tu vas continuer à
t'impliquer même dans l'humanitaire plus
tard et tout ça merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre d'être venu à l'occasion de
cette journée des droits de l'enfant lui
en cours qui va célébrer l'événement le
vendredi donc dès demain ce sera
mercredi au scarabée à Guyancourt
notamment avec votre association que
qu'il y a œuvre sur la ville et qu'on
peut régulièrement contacter je le redis
les coordonnées qui sont affichées merci
encore à vous quatre à l'occasion des
droits de l'enfant nous avons aussi
sollicité notre jeune stagiaire de 3e
actuellement d'observation au sein de la
rédaction de tvfils c'est donc Thomas
qui a vrai pour la séquence qui va
suivre notre question du jour
bonjour je m'appelle Thomas j'ai 14 ans
et je suis actuellement en troisième
j'effectue des stages aujourd'hui j'en
effectue un à tvfilm 78 où j'ai
interrogé des gens pour la journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant la
question étant pour vous quelle est les
droits des enfants pour vous quelles
sont les droits des enfants c'est déjà
d'être libre
s'exprimer
surtout et surtout d'être bien traité
les enfants de maintenant sont beaucoup
plus avantagés
comme moi tout à fait les enfants
doivent avoir des droits mais les
enfants doivent aussi avoir des devoirs
et il faut pas que les droits des
enfants empiète sur les devoirs des
enfants pour vous quelles sont les
droits des enfants qui doit être si vous
voulez norer loger respecter et puis
voilà qu'ils soient surtout heureux
qu'ils esquimaient ce qu'ils veulent
quand on est enfant on a envie d'être
heureux que le Père Noël soit comme en
généreux
nous poursuivons cette page dédiée à la
journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant et bienvenue à présent plateau
à Hélène Antonetti qui est photographe
bonsoir et à Marina quart de saut
bonsoir professeur des écoles aussi
photographe vous êtes donc des longs
courts nous allons continuer à parler
des droits de l'enfant avec une
exposition à la ferme du Mousseau dont
on va voir les images dans un instant
exposition qui se tient en ce moment des
photographies autour de la vie dans les
écoles des longs courts jusqu'en Inde
d'une soixantaine de clichés pour
comprendre comment on étudie en classe
la cour de récréation la façon dont ça
se déroule le réfectoire aussi c'est le
fruit de votre travail comment est venu
l'idée de cette exposition c'est une
rencontre
alors l'idée c'était que ben moi je suis
photographe à la ville d'Élancourt et
l'année dernière j'ai fait beaucoup de
photos autour du numérique à l'école et
j'ai vu ses enfants ses petits élans
courtois qui travaillaient sur les
tablettes avec beaucoup d'aisance et
j'avais envie de leur envoyer
j'avais envie de leur envoyer une image
de enfin qui souvent en images en fait
qui se voit et qui se compare avec
d'autres pays avec d'autres enfants de
pays et donc du coup j'ai commencé à
faire des photos au Maroc sauf que
j'avais pas assez de matière et je
savais que Marina on est amis et Marina
elle est enseignante et c'est un sujet
qui la touche beaucoup et du coup elle
avait fait pas mal de photos en Inde au
Pérou et là du coup on a été
complémentaire
justement sur cette opération vous
associez les enfants de votre classe
j'imagine tout ça pour ce qui est des
enfants de ma classe j'ai surtout eu un
travail préparatoire pour préparer un
petit peu les dessins de position parce
que les photos sont accompagnées de
dessin sur les représentations avant
tout des enfants on est beaucoup parti
de ça donc leur idée de ce qu'était
l'école ailleurs de pouvait être à
l'école en Inde donc Panama tout ça donc
aussi en accompagnant les voyages Hélène
et on a surtout pris des clichés parce
que autorisation parentale etc de vue
extérieures voilà le travail s'est fait
par thématique ensuite tout à fait au
tableau organisation en classe cours
d'école ça a été pensé plutôt comme ça
en thème de façon à ce qu'on puisse
travailler en regard avec les élèves
quand ils viennent ils te sont ils
échangent autour d'un thème
effectivement on a pensé la scénographie
pas par pays mais effectivement
par thème pour pouvoir trouver des
points communs des différences voilà qui
les interpelle il y a six classes déjà
qui ont visité l'exposition il en
ressort quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il vous disent beaucoup de
curiosité ils sont très intéressés
ils portent aucun jugement et ça c'est
génial ils sont vraiment dans ils sont
très intéressés
finalement tous les ce qui les rassemble
c'est que ils aiment apprendre ils
apprennent tous avec beaucoup
d'attention mais que c'est la manière
finalement c'est le support qui va
changer c'est il y en a qui sont assis
par terre il y en a qui sont assis sur
des tables mais finalement ils
apprennent la même chose des valeurs des
valeurs universelles donc ça fait naître
la discussion entre ces enfants vous
l'avez
on l'a ressenti effectivement les
clichés permettent d'engager des
discussions et et toutes les visites
sont différentes parce que finalement on
part de ce que les enfants voient ce
qu'il ressentent et c'est ça qui qui
enrichissant pour nous aussi parce que
finalement il nous apporte aussi leur
regard leur regard un peu curieux et
c'est tout à fait ils ont envie de
raconter aussi comment ça se passe hier
on a eu un garçon qui venait d'arriver
de de Mauritanie voilà il venait d'être
scolarisé depuis très peu de temps et du
coup en ressortant il a eu envie
d'expliquer à ses camarades comment ça
se passait pour lui l'école en
Mauritanie et donc on se dit que les
échanges se font dans ce lieu qui est la
ferme du Mousseau mais aussi ça va
continuer à l'école à l'extérieur ça me
prolongement 23 novembre l'exposition
ouverte au public et le but c'est
ensuite que ce soit itinérant ou de
rester sur quelque chose
donc vous sollicitez d'autres
municipalités c'est le moment de lancer
un appel éventuellement
très bien merci à toutes les deux
expositions à découvrir donc des écoles
du monde c'est à la ferme du Mousseau à
Élancourt merci donc la suite de ce
journal c'est avec le forum du
recrutement de Coignières 12e édition
nous avons suivi Abderrahman 31 ans en
recherche d'emploi il a déjà cumulé de
nombreux petits boulots mais il peine à
obtenir un emploi durable vous allez le
voir reportage d'Antony
armée de sa pile de CV Abderrahman vient
tenter sa chance parmi les centaines de
candidats dans les allées de ce forum de
recrutement à 31 ans se perd de trois
enfants à un peu fait tous les métiers
de chauffeur-livreur en passant par
maçon ou aide à la personne ce ne sont
pas les compétences qui manquent sur son
CV c'est vrai que c'est compliqué oui je
vous le mens pas c'est très compliqué de
trouver du travail malgré que j'ai de
l'expérience après avoir discuté avec
deux recruteurs il s'arrête au stand de
cette entreprise spécialisée dans la
toiture et l'isolation de maison vous
faites un peu de toiture façade
isolation menuiserie bon en fait moi
j'ai fait un petit peu de maçonnerie
j'ai fait du bâtiment 5 minutes
d'entretien il ressort avec un peu
d'espoir
on m'a expliqué comment l'entreprise
fonctionner et justement ça m'intéresse
que tout se passe bien d'après la
personne là qui recrute ils m'ont dit
que comme quoi normalement il y avait de
l'opportunité dans ce dans ce métier là
et qui recherche aussi lors de ses 12e
journée de à Coignières 35 entreprises
étaient présentes la plupart proposent
des postes en CDI sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou sa région
on est ouvert à tous types de profils en
fait on n'a pas d'arrêt comme on disait
sur ça qu'on est présent sur sur le
salon donc que ça soit Junior Senior
après c'est la motivation qui compte sur
les emplois de commerciaux notamment et
le savoir-être face aux clients donc à
partir du moment où les gens ont la
capacité à faire les choses et on le
projet à faire les choses on est on est
ouvert à tous types de profils dans les
Yvelines 7,2% des personnes actives
étaient au chômage au mois d'octobre
et pour l'actualité économique vous avez
rendez-vous juste après ce journal avec
Florian parfait pour fil Eco le magazine
de la rédaction chaque jeudi 18h30 pour
la première diffusion en direct les
postiers des Yvelines du secours et le
Secours populaire qui se sont associés
pour organiser une collecte de jouets
une centaine de sactes 1000 jouets qui
ont été rassemblés qui vont pouvoir être
distribués annuels des dons allant de la
peluche au consoles de jeux
à cette très bonne chose pour la
solidarité et du coup ça sera autant de
rue que joie collecter on savait pas
quel emploi ça allait donner
effectivement 1000 jouets sur une
collecte
ça fait c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup et
ça correspond à
un huitième des publics donc c'est pas
négligeable on s'attendait pas du tout à
avoir un talent engouement et ça montre
les vraiment les valeurs de solidarité
qui sont véhiculées par les postiers
puisque ce ne sont que des cadeaux des
objets des jouets qui ont été ramenés
par les postiers sans collecte à
l'extérieur sans appel à nos clients
alors c'était un don complètement libre
on n'a pas donné de tranches d'âge en
revanche les seuls consignes qu'on ait
donné c'est des jouets neufs ou en
excellent état
solidarité toujours un salon des vins et
des saveurs proposés à Maurepas pour la
deuxième année consécutive le Lion's
Club de Maurepas Saint-Quentin Doyen a
organisé cette manifestation qui a
rassemblé environ 800 personnes autour
de stand de gourmand animation festive
un peu plus d'un mois des fêtes de fin
d'année également je vous le disais
solidaire les exposants présents ce
week-end à Maurepas ont payé des droits
d'entrée 3600 euros collectés sommes
reversés au profit d'Action au local on
écoute Thérèse Monet à ce sujet
nous organisons donc des grandes actions
et tous les bénéfices sont reversés au
profit de nos associations que l'on
soutient les projets en fait on fait
partir soit de jeunes enfants de de mon
repas en vacances pour la première fois
quand ils sont issus de famille
défavorisées par exemple
ou d'autres d'autres projets on soutient
des associations
notre président cette année a eu l'idée
de d'acheter peut-être
une voiture pour transporter des
handicapés nous sommes en train d'en
discuter
50 ans en Yvelines ne seraient pas
l'agglomération telle qu'on la connaît
sans la patte de l'EPA l'établissement
public d'aménagement Jean-Paul aldy on a
été le directeur général entre 1988 et
1993 5 années où tous ces jouets tout
s'est accéléré il revient sur les
principaux dossiers nous l'avons
rencontré il était sur 50 ans en
Yvelines récemment
Jean-Paul aldui n'était jamais revenu à
50 ans en Yvelines une agglomération
qu'il a quitté en 1993 il était alors
directeur général de l'établissement
public d'aménagement 20 ans plus tard
celui que l'on appelait Zébulon en
raison de son énergie à faire les choses
et revenu à 50 ans en Yvelines pour y
présenter son dernier ouvrage non sans
émotion une sorte de pudeur à revenir
sur un territoire que j'avais quitté et
où c'était achevé ma vie de
fonctionnaire d'État de techniciens de
la ville
c'est au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qu'il est venu
rencontrer ses anciens collègues et amis
il se souvient que le théâtre n'a jamais
déterminé
normalement sur la façade du théâtre
dans les petites alvéoles que vous voyez
devait y avoir des statues il manque des
statues sur cette façade il manque tout
enfin un jour que l'on mette dans
chacune de ces niches une statue tel que
c'était prévu dans le premier projet
autre souvenir fort le Technocentre
Renault à Guyancourt sa dernière
décision la vente des terrains la régie
Renaud une histoire surprenante ça a
démarré par quelqu'un dont je tiré le
nom qui est venu me voir dans mon petit
déjeunier de mes loyers de la ferme de
bévoyer et qui m'a dit je peux pas vous
dire qui je suis je peux pas vous dire
quelle société je suis mais j'ai besoin
de 300 hectares et je c'est pour
produire 300 400 500 600 mille mètres
carrés on sait pas
ça fait drôle quand même quelqu'un vous
dites c'est un charlatan c'était sérieux
et je pouvais même pas donner le nom de
l'entreprise à Roland Nadeau
il fallait qu'il me fasse confiance
et oui parce que on est entre nous
le projet de la région Renault si c'est
c'était les graines le regard que
Jean-Paul alduit porte aujourd'hui sans
la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
dithyrambique sans autre forme de
réserve il parle d'un exemple unique au
monde il y a des tas de vie nouvelle
mais les autres vie nouvelle sont des
vieilles nouvelles essentiellement
d'habitat 50 ans en Yvelines a une
puissance économique impressionnante et
voyez une vie nouvelle qui a une telle
puissance économique c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel et je crois à mon avis que
c'est unique au monde éventuellement
brésilien mais Brasilia c'est un autre
sujet les gens ne connaissent mal 50
années de 5 ans en Yvelines un déficit
de notoriété
quand à mon avis elle est sous-évaluée
en termes de notoriété par rapport à ce
que 50 ans en Yvelines est devenu un
dossier malgré tout 50 ans en Yvelines
aurait pu aller plus vite selon
Jean-Paul lui la ville intelligente
cette ville avait tous les moyens pour
être le laboratoire de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la ville intelligence
c'est-à-dire la ville qui utilise toutes
ces nouvelles technologies de la
communication pour faire en sorte que
tout citoyen avec son smartphone sachent
exactement ce qu'il a derrière dans le
commerce aussi là devant dans l'hôtel
les services publics l'arrivée du bus
les parts de stationnement la sécurité
de la police etc la vie nouvelle aurait
pu être la ville modèle la ville
exceptionnelle aujourd'hui on va à
Fribourg en Allemagne pour voir ça ouais
c'est sûr on aurait pu venir à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc là
peut-être que là mais je m'en suis
expliqué avec le président Rogier les
obstacles sont essentiellement des
obstacles juridiques avec les différents
opérateurs d'après ce que j'ai compris
mais ça c'est bien français après 50 ans
en Yvelines j'en peux la Ledu a quitté
la fonction territoriale pour s'engager
en politique d'abord mère de Perpignan
puis ironie de l'histoire président
lui-même d'une communauté
d'agglomération il a dit-il d'ailleurs
beaucoup appris ici
fin de ce journal rendez-vous vendredi
pour l'actualité du jour et l'essentiel
de la semaine très bonne soirée